what's the deal with airplane
peanuts after a mysterious three-year
Hiatus Daniel TSH is finally back but
his return is coming in one of the most
unexpected and shocking ways possible
after spending the last 12 years
straight avoiding the podcast world like
the plague I've avoided listening to or
being on any podcast that's ever been
recorded and even filming sketches
making fun of the industry welcome to
the AR sucks podcast who's ready for AR
again Daniel TSH made a surprise
announcement last week uploading episode
one of Tosh show a brand new weekly
podcast hosted by none other than Daniel
Tosh welcome to Tosh.0 nope wrong show
all right welcome to Tosh show I'll be
honest sounds very similar it's almost
as if we're intentionally trying to be
confusing but in a world that's already
so oversaturated with highquality comedy
podcasts is there anything unique about
Tas show that makes it different from
all the others or is this just another
new podcast to add to the
list to show the first episode of toas
show premiered last week on YouTube and
immediately had people talking with
almost no promotion to speak of Daniel
TSH uploaded episode one of his new
podcast completely out of the blue to an
allnew YouTube channel with zero
subscribers one week later andas show
already has 150,000 subs and their only
video is closing in on 1 million views
there's no doubt a lot of this initial
excitement is due to Daniel TSH being
out of the public eye for most of the
last 3 years after Comedy Central
canceled Tosh.0 in 2020 but another
reason for the massive amount of
interest in TSH show is that Daniel TSH
has been the most elusive podcast guest
of all time and the Mystery behind one
of this era's most well-known comedic
figures not having his own podcast and
refusing to go on others is finally
coming to an end and honestly that's all
the promotion TSH show needs nowadays it
seems like every comedy podcast can be
easily put into one of three categories
solo ranters friendly Duos and solo
interviewers but after watching episode
one of Tosh show it doesn't seem like
he's going to be following any of these
models although TSH will be interviewing
people from time to time don't expect to
see your favorite comedian sitting with
TSH promoting their new special anytime
soon in fact maybe don't expect to see
any comedians at all unlike most
podcasts Tas show is not going for
guests with the biggest names in this
field in fact it's quite the opposite
just like the viral internet videos on
Tosh.0 the guests on TSH show don't need
to be funnier than Daniel nor do they
need to be famous his guest is just
there to create an angle for TSH to work
for example interviewing his wife's
gynecologist is a great way to set him
up to make jokes at his own speed and in
his own style throughout the entirety of
episode one to the viewer it doesn't
matter if the guest is a known person or
not because we're not watching for the
guest it's almost better to interview a
completely random person so the host
becomes the focal point and the
questions he's asking become the jokes
it's a very different vibe then say for
example theovon and Bobby Lee getting
together on a podcast who are still
going to be entertaining throughout with
non-stop jokes and hilarious improv but
in their version no clear Direction
topic truth or person in the driver's
seat let me tell you something in all
honesty this is the reason I agreed to
do this show iHeart was like will you do
the show and I'm like I don't know I
don't want to interview comedians I
don't want to interview celebrities but
like if you let and I said this I swear
to you I said if you let me interview
like my wife's gynecologist like then
I'll do the show and they're like well
yeah but that won't ever happen he
probably won't let you and I'm not that
interesting no you're extremely
interesting for any fans of old school
Tosh.0 this is very exciting news Tosh
show basically sounds like it's going to
be a long form version of Tosh.0 with
less production value and more of a
theme Daniel will still take time to
touch on Sports and current events as
well as popular online videos but now
without a clock counting down his exact
time to react and unlike most long form
pods this is still a tight almost
written show there's plenty of editing
cuts and not much wasted time between
questions it seems like most Comics can
view their onstage work as their actual
product and their podcast as a more of
relaxed behind the-scenes glimpse into
their lives whereas with Tas show it's
clear that this is a plan performance
for our viewing pleasure there's no
wasted time or words spoken that aren't
meant to be funny and interesting the
biggest difference between Tosh show and
Tosh.0 is that I will be wearing glasses
occasionally and sitting down because
it's a podcast and you're just listening
but you can also watch so it's pretty
much the same show big difference
chiming in off camera way more than I'll
ever feel comfortable with it's my good
friend and Tahoe neighbor Eddie he
co-created Tosh.0 and Tosh show he's my
Larry David if Larry was slightly less
funny and bought his jeans at Costco
which makes me Jerry Seinfeld minus the
Scientology phase and fear of performing
in front of people under the age of 30
I'll do 45 minutes on the burden of
white privilege at any college campus in
this country okay it's still unclear if
we'll ever see Daniel TSH as a guest on
other podcasts but it's at least nice to
see him hosting in the meantime plus
we'll always have this clip of when
Bobby Lee thought he was getting Daniel
TSH on tiger belly there's some names in
here I was like you know what they're
going to say no but I'm going to reach
out anyway right new Bob new Bob so I
went down and I got down to the te's
right Titus and I saw Daniel Tosh so I
go hey it's Bobby Lee this probably
isn't your number anymore but can you do
my podcast please I love you he responds
right away
he goes Bobby I would love to brother
have your folks send me the details and
he's like thank God I didn't change my
number right so sweet sweet lovely so I
go thanks dude exclamation goes of
course I'm honored and I almost cried
I'm like oh my God this guy's something
going on so the next day it says Bobby
your podcast today I'm so sorry about
you and Kila he goes all into it then
this is where it gets fishy he goes
let's get together this weekend I'll be
in La it'd be great to catch up love you
man so I'm like wow he's religious or I
don't know like I'm around it's been
tough let's get coffee or something let
me know then he responds right away
straight say strong brother and then
this and
that and then I look up at you know I I
don't have his F picture saved but I
look up into this photo right here oh my
God and it says Tosh I don't know what
that means so I Google TSH and it's the
same Indian
guy pleasure
wait I didn't even know this I told you
Whitney
No guest spots from last week The Joe
Rogan Experience talked with Dwayne The
Rock Johnson and Mike Baker mat and
Shane the Tim Dylan show and the Adam
friedin show all did not have guests
Whitney Cummings was the guest on
Whiskey Ginger Whitney was also on tiger
belly flagrant talk with sugar Shan Ali
two bears one cave was Burton Tom Tom
and Bert kill Tony this week was with
steo and Adrien aushi steo was also on
Chrissy chaos taste buds battled popcorn
vers peanuts with Ari shafir Joe D was
on are you garbage and samarel was on
first date the problem on a one night
stand with your place is they have to
want to leave and sometimes with the one
night stand if if it's over I I'm pretty
good at feeling where I'm not wanted so
I know it' be like okay well it's been
great but sometimes people will like
overstay and you're kind of like all
right I guess we're still doing this
it's 400 p.m. the next day kind of had
plans do you find it hard to like escape
a situation like that yeah if if the
person doesn't read social cues you know
yeah you have to be like what kind of
person can't read social cues you know
and then you're like well it's the
person who [__] me on the first date I
guess so this past weekend with theovon
spoke with Dana White Jessica kerson was
on hey babe why Mage talked with Nate
Jackson we might be drunk was with Jimmy
Carr Joe Koy was on the blocks podcast
Dan Soder was on take your shoes off be
and Ian with Jordan welcome to Jeremiah
Watkins Aaron Berg and Mike Fiona were
on you know what dude the honeydude
talked with lwis black and Tom rhods was
on the Harland Highway as far as new
standup specials that are either out
right now or coming out out soon Jessica
Kiron no material is a new crowdwork
hour out on YouTube we also have Whitney
Cummings mouthy out on only fans TV and
Matt rif natural selection out on
Netflix another new special out right
now Joe dumbrowski don't eat the Crayons
is available on his YouTube channel
kindergarten is the best grade because
the bar is just so unbearably low I was
just going to work drunk every day and
the kids were like wow the tall man's
extra fun
today he keeps playing this game called
stumble he's good at it and a few
specials in the works right now that
will be coming out soon stavos halia fat
Rascal premieres December 5th on Netflix
Brad Williams starfish will be available
on his website December 21st which is
also the shortest day of the year and
Kevin James irregardless is coming out
on Prime video sometime this winter we
also had Joe koi record his new Netflix
special at the Kings theater in Brooklyn
on November 10th and 11th with an
expected 2024 Premiere and not
technically a standup special but two
alltime greats Chris Rock and Kevin Hart
are releasing a documentary about their
friendship and careers on Netflix
December 12th titled Headliners only
other than that please be sure to
subscribe to joke world right now for
more videos keeping you in the comedy
Loop let me know in the comments what
you think of Tas show and what other
professions you'd like to see him
interview also comedians funniest
bombing Stories part two is out right
now on this channel you can find it on
the end screen right after this thank
you for
watching at joke
world that's did it joke world
and the world is
wld that's a great uh YouTube channel
joke World check it out